this summer caribbean carnivals across
the country finally got back on the road
celebrating the culture and
contributions the caribbean islands have
made all over the
uk and in manchester it was extra
special marking 50 years since it all
began
it was essential because as a
marginalised community that came
together 50 years ago anyway
to show how it's grown and diversified
and that
as a people as a caribbean people our
heritage culture
matters
it was it was massive
manchester saw thousands but london is
expecting millions and preparations are
almost complete
[Music]
costumes like these are made months in
advance and dance moves perfected
see has been designing costumes from her
flat all summer hard work but worth it i
think it's important because it's been a
really difficult time for our
communities i think hope it's hit our
communities more than maybe other people
and um
and i just think it's the time for
everyone to get together you know a lot
of people are still quite nervous about
going out but it's just a way for
everyone just to kind of let go of all
their worries and just
um i don't know that's a feeling of
freedom isn't it and that's what
carnival is about i think as well this
weekend sound systems will boom the ear
will be filled with the sweet smell of
jerk chicken and millions of hips will
be swaying down these streets after
three long years organizers hope it's an
event everyone can enjoy a priority for
police too
this year at carnival we are going to
have safer spaces
we're working really closely with
partners around safer spaces and these
are places where women and girls if they
feel unsafe or they're uncomfortable or
they need support they can come to those
safer spaces
for us to
listen to their concerns and investigate
those concerns
the police aren't the only ones getting
ready for the storm of celebration about
to hit west london it may be quiet now
but up to 2 million carnival goers are
expected to turn up this weekend
dancing and partying until the city
shakes shaman freeman powell sky news